[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días un
programa semanal en el que analizamos la
actualidad más destacada del continente
africano en esta edición hablamos de la
relación entre el kremlin el grupo
paramilitar ruso Wagner y el continente
africano para comprender mejor este
contexto Contamos con la experticia de
periodista y destacado especialista
sobre el grupo Wagner la misión de paz
de la ONU en Mali conocida como minusma
tiene previsto abandonar el país a
finales de 2023 esta decisión ha sido
tomada a petición de la junta militar
que gobierna en bamaco los militares
acusan a la minusma de no haber cumplido
con su misión y optaron por el grupo
Wagner en su lucha contra los yihadistas
Y por último dejamos el continente
africano y nos trasladamos a Brasil para
conocer a un peluquero que ha
desarrollado una técnica exclusiva para
colocar rastas en personas que padecen
calvicie Total descubrimos como este
profesional logró dar una nueva
apariencia y confianza a aquellos que
pensaban que las rastas eran
inalcanzables
comenzamos tras la rebelión y las
acciones del grupo Wagner ante el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin ha
surgido una serie de preguntas sobre el
futuro la expansión y las operaciones de
este ejército privado de mercenarios en
el continente africano Donde ha
establecido una presencia significativa
desde hace seis años conversamos con
periodista especializado sobre el grupo
quien nos ofreció información sobre cómo
Wagner Ha logrado establecerse en los
países africanos donde actualmente tiene
una presencia destacada
en el caso de la República
centroafricana llegaron a vangui a
finales de 2017
la idea era proporcionar apostard cancha
de Gaga nuevo presidente del país
seguridad y un medio para reconquistar
ciertas zonas de la nación que estaban
en manos de grupos armados la llegada de
Wagner a la República centroafricana en
2017 y luego su aumento de poder en 2018
se hicieron con el acuerdo y con el
consentimiento de las autoridades rusas
de la diplomacia rusa y de hecho todo
comenzó en este momento con las
conversaciones que habían tenido lugar
entre sargueilabrov ministro ruso de
asuntos exteriores y Foster and Castro
a finales de 2021
Al principio para ofrecer seguridad y
permitir a los coroneles y a la junta
maliense reconquistar partes del
territorio que estaban en manos de los
islamistas
hoy en día por dar algunas cifras hay
mil mil cuatrocientos mercenarios Wagner
en la República centroafricana y
alrededor de 1500 mercenarios en
malínado
también llegó a Libia en torno a 2017 y
Los mercenarios siguen combatiendo en el
sur del país con acceso a bases aéreas
el último país de importancia es Sudán
donde también llegaron hacia 2017
lo que comenzó como una cooperación
militar con los regímenes establecido ha
evolucionado rápidamente hacia una
diversidad de actividades económicas
incursionando en los negocios y sobre
todo en la explotación de los recursos
naturales de los países
ahora sabemos que este grupo estaba
financiado en gran parte por el estado
ruso Vladimir Putin habló de eso hace
unos días y reveló que el estado ruso
había puesto a disposición cada año
alrededor de mil millones de dólares
para el funcionamiento del grupo Wagner
Pero la idea del grupo Wagner es poder
financiarse al menos en parte así que de
empresa de seguridad privada tradicional
ha evolucionado hacia una compañía que
es en realidad una multinacional con
varias empresas implicadas en diferentes
sectores económicos como el oro los
diamantes
de madera incluso los licores y el café
donde se hace así que es bastante
extenso y todo esto permite ganar aquí
allá a unos cuantos millones de euros
unas cuantas decenas de millones de
euros y por lo tanto poder disponer de
financiación propia para pagar hombres
armas y una maquinaria de propaganda que
también ha hecho que el grupo Wagner
tenga tanto éxito
el especialista nos dio también sus
perspectivas en relación al futuro del
grupo Wagner en el continente africano
considerando su reciente revuelta contra
el kremlin y las tensiones entre Jenny y
Vladimir Putin
creo que la presencia de Wagner sobre
todo en la República centroafricana es
demasiado fuerte para que Vladimir Putin
pueda simplemente decir retiremos a
Wagner y pongamos otra empresa en su
lugar o retiremos a los hombres de
prehin y proponer otra solución
los hombres desde el continente tienen
una conexión real con los políticos y
con los círculos empresariales por lo
que en mi opinión Esto es lo esencial
para Moscú y significa que es probable
que Wagner continúe en su forma actual
lo que va a ocurrir es quizás algunos
ajustes en la jerarquía y un mayor
control por parte del kremlin
continuamos en Mali donde como lo
decíamos el grupo Wagner ha establecido
una presencia significativa el ministro
maliense de asuntos exteriores abdula y
diopt se expresó ante el consejo de
seguridad de las Naciones Unidas en
Nueva York el 16 de junio exigiendo La
retirada inmediata de la misión de
mantenimiento de paz de la minusma en el
país
dos semanas después los 15 miembros del
Consejo de Seguridad adoptaron una
resolución unánime poniendo fin a la
misión para algunos analistas
líder del grupo paramilitar Wagner
desempeñó un papel activo en la salida
de la minusma
la salida de la minusma adoptada por
unanimidad los representantes están casi
todos de acuerdo han votado a favor
Aunque a regañadientes
Aunque lamentamos profundamente la
decisión del gobierno de transición de
abandonar la minusma y el hecho de que
ello perjudicará a la población
malinense hemos votado a favor de la
resolución porque estamos satisfechos
con el plan de
otros fueron aún más lejos
no creemos que la asociación con el
grupo Wagner pueda proporcionar
estabilidad o seguridad a largo plazo al
pueblo de Manny con la adopción de esta
resolución Rusia celebró lo que
considera el respeto a una decisión
soberana tomada por las autoridades
malienses el proceso el proceso de
retirada de la minusma comenzará el 1 de
julio y finalizará el 31 de diciembre de
2023 el gobierno de la República de Mali
cumple y seguirá cumpliendo los
compromisos que ha contraído al respecto
la República de Mali sigue dispuesta a
cooperar con todos los socios que lo
deseen
fue creada en 2013 tras una ofensiva
armada de grupos yihadistas desde el
norte del país pero desde entonces su
alcance se ha visto drásticamente
reducido por las autoridades de
transición la junta gobernante y una
parte de la población acusan a la
minusma de haber fracasado en su misión
de seguridad y de haber conseguido poco
en los últimos 10 años
cambiamos de tema en el Reino Unido el
gobierno conservador encabezado por el
Primer Ministro enfrentado en
importante revés en su política
migratoria los tribunales han fallado en
contra de su plan de deportar Ruanda a
los refugiados y solicitantes de asilo
que llegan al país a través del Canal de
la Mancha a pesar de que Londres y
chigali habían acordado esta medida el
año pasado los tribunales británicos han
determinado que Ruanda no puede ser
considerado un país seguro dadas las
circunstancias actuales nuestra
corresponsal en gigali Marian condena
nos trae las reacciones ante esta
decisión
Ruanda es uno de los países más seguros
del mundo al menos ese dice el gobierno
ruandés en un comunicado de presa en el
que impugna la decisión del tribunal de
apelación británico el comunicado
precisa y osito textualmente que Ruanda
está
significativamente a gestionar el
impacto de la crisis migratoria mundial
lejos de estar abatida por la decisión
de los jueces el gobierno Irlandés
renueva su compromiso para que el
acuerdo funciona un acuerdo que pruebe
la deportación aruanda de los
inmigrantes que lleguen ilegalmente
arena Unido desde que se firmó hace más
de un año el acuerdo ha sido duramente
criticado por las ong y Derechos Humanos
justamente el acnur ha acogido con la
satisfacción la decisión del tribunal
este acuerdo ya ha costado al
contribuyente británico más
recientemente millones de dólares sin
que solo un migrante haya salido direno
Unidos para que Gali por su parte el
jefe del gobierno conservador británico
ha anunciado su intención de apelar
y terminamos nuestro programa en Brasil
Por qué queremos compartir una historia
inspiradora desde Río de Janeiro un
talentoso peluquero ha creado una
técnica revolucionar ya llamada Bad lock
que permite colocar rastas en personas
completamente calvas esta Innovación
está destinada a transformar la estética
de aquellos afrodescendientes que han
perdido prematuramente su cabello y
africarioca su salón de belleza tiene
una misión muy especial se dedica a
ayudar a recuperar las raíces culturales
y estéticas de la población negra en
Brasil que constituye el 56% de la
población total el informe es de Valeria
sakone y amiguidara
thiago llega de madrugada Río de Janeiro
con un propósito recuperar su cabellera
afrow nunca me molestó ser calvo Pero me
gusta esta cosa camaleónica y aún más en
el sentido de recuperar mis raíces a
través del pelo
ancestralidad a través de
ha recorrido casi 500 kilómetros para
realizar un tratamiento novedoso le van
a poner unos baldrox eso es red logs
para calvos es una técnica desarrollada
en este salón de belleza afro si yo no
muestro cómo estaba antes nadie en mis
redes sociales va a creer el resultado
el proceso empezó hace 4 meses
tiene que parar de rasurarse la cabeza
después el salón hizo un estudio
pormenorizado de su cráneo para
desarrollar una base a medida donde
ahora van a injertar los baldrox a ese
procedimiento todo este procedimiento se
hace con una aguja de crochet no usamos
pegamento ni tampoco sustancias que
puedan dañar el cuero cabelludo
hace falta maestría paciencia y bastante
tiempo porque demora más de seis horas
no duele incluso es relajante te ayuda a
quedarte tranquilo a pensar
cómo se colocan los es el secreto mejor
guardado de esta barbería
es una técnica totalmente autodidacta y
autoral suelo romantizar esta historia y
siempre digo que fue una inspiración
divina
Lucas cuenta que muchos clientes
recuperan su autoestima cuando se ven en
el espejo con su pelo afro estás listo
madre mía estoy muy guapo muy diferente
me encanta
tiago no consigue ocultar su
satisfacción el coste del tratamiento si
la entre los 400 y los 800 dólares una
inversión de la que ningún ex calvo se
ha arrepentido hasta hoy
así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa Gracias por acompañarnos la
actualidad internacional sigue en
Francia 24 y France 24.com